Herzlich willkommen zu unserer Live-Folge Dicke Bretter. Heute von den Datenspuren in Dresden. Ich bin Elina oder auch Calisi und zusammen mit der wunderbaren Constanze Kurz und Elisa Lindinger, die heute leider nicht da sein kann, werden wir heute ein bisschen über Policy-Themen reden, worum es genau geht, werde ich gleich verraten. Und wir haben auch wieder einen wunderbaren Gast, nämlich Daniel, der sich auch gleich selber vorstellen wird. Und in unseren vergangenen Folgen haben wir uns schon mit der UN beschäftigt und mit der EU und mit dem Bundestag und mit Gremien, die technische Standards machen. Und wir gehen jetzt in der Flughöhe wieder noch ein Stück weiter runter. Und zwar soll es heute mal um Landespolitik gehen, ganz besonders um Landespolitik in Sachsen. Und dazu haben wir Daniel eingeladen, der noch Mitglied im Landtag ist. Daniel, stell dich doch mal vor.
Der spart ja auch Geld. Das hat insbesondere hier, so im Südosten, aber generell im Süden der Republik, ich meine jetzt der gesamten Bundesrepublik, auch eine sehr lebendige KMU-Szene gibt, die Open Source nutzt und so und entwickelt. Komm an, ist ja auch ein Wirtschaftsstandort Faktor, oder?
Wir haben sogar in Dresden einen Open Source Software-Verein. Ich weiß nicht, Alaska. Cloud ist die Domain. Alaska.EV ist der Name, also der beschäftigt sich tatsächlich mit Open Source Software im Container- und Cluster-Bereich, also alles, was irgendwie mit Cloud zu tun hat, machen die da. Und in Leipzig macht die Software-Szene mehr Umsatz als die Automotive. Und ja, wir tragen auch das Softwareland Sachsen-Logo.
Du hast mir eigentlich den Wirtschaftsstandort Sachsen vorangebracht, wenn man mal im Politgesprächs bleibt.
Ich bin ja so. Du wolltest die Ziele noch haben.
Naja, und vielleicht jetzt im Hinblick auf diesen Bericht, macht es ja dann wahrscheinlich Sinn für die CW-Gesellschaft, diese Berichte weiterhin im Auge zu behalten und gegebenenfalls noch weiter dafür zu sorgen, dass da mehr passiert, oder? Eher auch eine Maßnahme.
Ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn die Zivilgesellschaft den Finger in die Wunde legt an der Stelle und dann in der Sächsischen Staatskanzlei immer mal wieder nachfragt, wie denn der aktuelle Stand ist.
Das ist ja relativ leicht zu machen für die Zivilgesellschaft. Sie könnte sich einen beliebigen Abgeordneten, der kooperationswillig ist.
Das geht ganz einfach, ich denke auch, man sucht sich den personalen Wahlkreisabgeordneten von der freundlich ausgerichteten Partei und fragt mal, ob die eine Kleine Anfrage stellen können, wie es denn aussieht damit. Genau, weil sie sind ja auch, also bisher hat sich die Staatsregierung an die Aufträge aus dem sächsischen Landtag gehalten. Von daher gehe ich erstmal davon aus, dass man sich auch diese Ziele, die man sich gesteckt hat, die ich jetzt mittlerweile auch gefunden habe, dass man das auch...
Und dann sagt man die Ziele.
Genau, wir haben festgelegt, dass wir für die Relation von Open Source Software zur gesamten Softwarelandschaft zum Stichtag 30. Juni 2028 20% haben wollen. Also eine Steigerung von den 6.000 irgendwas Einträgen sollen in Zukunft 20% Open Source Software sein.
Entschuldigung, aber hier mischt sich schon eine gewisse Enttäuschung ein bei mir. Das finde ich ein bisschen unambitioniert. Hätte das nicht ein bisschen mehr sein können? So 50?
Und müsste man ja die gesamte Liste, die man jetzt schon an proprietärer Software hat, die geht ja auch nicht weg.
Naja, das wäre ja die nächste Frage.
Das wäre eher bei den Neubeschaffungen.
Naja, meine Frage wäre eher zu sagen, gibt es in dieser Open Source Strategie auch ein Ziel, was heißt, irgendwie mal gucken, welche Lizenzen wir wirklich brauchen?
Also die Lizenzen, die in der Open Source Software Strategie festgelegt sind, das sind die OSI-zertifizierten Sachen. Also an der Stelle hat man schon aufgepasst. Da hat auch die Open Source Business Alliance und so weiter, auch die Zivilgesellschaft mit an der richtigen Stelle ihre Meinung.
Ja, aber schneller ging es nicht. Also man konnte jetzt nicht sagen, also kämpel ich weiter mit anderen.
20 Prozent haben wir schon mal in der öffentlichen Verwaltung Software beschafft.
Ja, ach man, ja, die Realität....
vier Jahren verändern kann. Also die Ziele der Strategie gehen alle auf 2028. Da hat man quasi eine Legislaturzeit.
Oder könnte man jetzt sagen...
35,25 Prozent zu kommen ist...
Man muss dicke Bretter bohren.
Da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht. Genau, wir wollen 25 Prozent in Zukunft als komplette Open Source Neubaustragung machen. Wir wollen 2024 dem Zendes beitreten, also dem Zentrum für digitale Souveränität. Wir wollen Open Desk, also den digitalen Arbeitsplatz in der Verwaltung einführen in Sachsen. Wir haben, soweit ich das schon gesehen hab, einen sächsischen Account auf Open Code. Ja, wir haben auch tatsächlich schon Open Source Projekte, die da vorbereitet werden, da hochgeladen zu werden. Also diesen Tanker umzudrehen oder in eine bestimmte Richtung zu lenken, das ist schon nicht so einfach. Und auch wenn du jetzt vielleicht höhere Zahlen erwartet hättest, ich vielleicht auch, aber ich weiß ja nicht, wenn du mich gefragt hast, bevor ich in den Sächsischen Landtag gekommen bin, 2018 oder was, ob das jetzt das Ziel ist, was wir erreichen können. Hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht gesagt.
Der Punkt ist wahrscheinlich der Tanker, den du erwähnst, dass du jetzt sagst, das ist eben eine große Gebilde, was man da einfach nur so sehr langsam in eine andere Richtung bewegen kann, wie man das eben mit der Metapher Tanker sich gut vorstellen kann.
Du musst vielleicht noch dazu sagen, wir hatten, wie wahrscheinlich in jedem Bundesland auch, wir hatten ja gerade schon mal Corona-Pandemie, Anfang der Diskussion um die Corona-Warn-App. Und viele Bundesländer sind da in diese Lukavalle getappt und viel Geld verschwendet worden. Und na ja, wir haben das in Sachsen nicht gemacht. Wir waren, glaube ich, das erste Bundesland, was in der Corona-Schutz-Verordnung die Corona-Warn-App aufgenommen hat. Das war ein, wie ich finde, damals ein Meilstein. Und wir haben alle erst mal verstanden, was wir für Diskussionen geführt haben, wie diese Corona-Warn-App funktioniert und diese ganzen dezentral-wörse-zentral-Geschichten usw. Das war schon...
Ja, wir könnten im CTC ja auch ein Lied davon singen, also so ist es nicht.
Aber es war immerhin erfolgreich.
Da hat sich ja die Zivilgesellschaft durchgesetzt am Ende und es war wirklich toll mit zu beobachten. Und das hat auch, zumindest war das mal eine Beobachtung, in der sächsischen Staatsregierung, das ist ja sozusagen mein Wirkkreis, in dem ich irgendwas mitbekomme, hat das zu einem positiven Umdenken geführt, dass das jetzt nicht das Teufelszeug ist und dass das irgendwie doch vielleicht gar keine so eine dumme Idee ist, wenn man öffentliche Geld aufwendet, dass da am Ende ein öffentliches Gut rauskommt. Das ist auch die Erfahrung, die ich beim sächsischen Digitalpreis gemacht habe. Dann kommt die leiser erinnerte Digitalagentur Sachsen nach der Verleihung des Open Source Preises zu mir. Ah, jetzt habe ich das verstanden mit dem Open Source Gedanken. Das ist ja so eine menschliche Geschichte, so eine... Ja, also zur Erklärung, da sind den ersten Preis an der Stelle, hat das Gieß mein Kids Projekt aus Leipzig geworden. Das ist, glaube ich, ein Ableger aus Berlin, also wo man einen Baum adoptieren kann und dann sieht, wie viel es geregnet hat und ob der gegossen werden muss und sich quasi mit Daten aus der Stadt, für die Stadt, gegen den Klimawandel, mit Open Source Software einsetzen kann. Und diese Geschichte konnte so, das war so eine schöne, herzliche Gemeinschafts- oder gemeinwohlorientierte Geschichte, da haben alle verstanden, diesen Gedanken, der hinter Open Source Software steckt.
Manchmal sind es ja auch die kleinen Projekte, die greifbar werden und mit denen man was vermitteln kann, was viel, viel größer ist. Ja, stimmt. Man vergisst manchmal in dieser Nerd- und Tech-Community, dass die Gedanken, die jemand kennt, die hinter Open Source stecken, nicht Allgemeinwissen sind und dass man die erst vermitteln muss.
Nein, also zu erklären, was Open Source Software ist, war eine der Hauptaufgaben in den letzten 40 Jahren. Also, dass war immer wieder überhaupt das Verständnis, wie Software im Allgemeinen funktionieren. Wir haben ja heute noch gar nicht über KI gesprochen. Das soll ja jetzt in Zukunft alle Probleme...
Doch, doch, wir haben mit einem KI-Witz angefangen. Hattest du nicht mal ein Start-up mit KI? Du hast das nur anders genannt.
Das hat er nur nicht so genannt, deswegen war es nicht so erfolgreich.
Also, ich muss jetzt mal noch kurz was anderes losführen. Also, du hast vorhin irgendwie, der Dämpfrost ja, relativ deutlich Ausdruck verliehen. Aber jetzt habe ich einen ganz anderen Eindruck. Also, jetzt habe ich den Eindruck, dass du auch sehr gerne diese gestaltende Politik gemacht hast. Wenn es erfolgreich jetzt, weil das bestimmt nicht in allen Fällen war, aber wenn es jetzt erfolgreich ist, die ja auch Freude macht. Was hast du dir jetzt vermittelt? Landespolitik kann Spaß und Erfolge bringen, richtig?
Ja, definitiv. Ich habe ein schönes Beispiel, bei dem das wirklich so ganz plastisch wird. Ich habe ein Komma und zwei Wörter in den Koalitionsvertrag eingeführt. Komma, Jugendhakt. Das waren die effektivsten 200 Wörter in dem ganzen, also für mich auf jeden Fall in dem Koalitionsvertrag. Und das hat hier zu, keine Ahnung, drei neuen Labs. Und also die Arbeit hat Jugendhakt gemacht, nicht ich. Aber die Förderung ist da durchgekommen. Und wir hatten hier Hackathons und so weiter.
Gerber, letztendlich war es ja nicht das Komma und die zwei Wörter, sondern am Ende hast du ja den Koalitionsvertrag mit Leben erfüllt, indem du dich dafür politisch eingesetzt hast, dass diese zwei Worte nach dem Komma auch irgendwie umgesetzt werden und praktische...
So ein Koalitionsvertrag, von der Koalition beschlossen, der ist schon was wert.
Oh, come on. Das reden wir gerade. Das haben wir so in der Menge gelesen.
Okay, aber vielleicht, ich fand das eigentlich gerade ein schönes positives Ende, bevor wir über uneingehaltene Koalitionsvertragsversprechen sprechen. Das ist ein anderes Thema, Sicherheitspaket. Also wir haben ja schon viel über EU, UN, Bundestag und so gesprochen. Das ist auch irgendwie alles relativ gleich frustrierend, aber ich finde, was irgendwie jetzt hier nochmal ganz schön klar geworden ist, ist, dass man natürlich auch auf Landesebene sich für Dinge einsetzen kann und dass da vielleicht auch die Schwelle ein bisschen niedriger ist, an die Politikmachenden zu kommen, weil man eine Ansprechperson vor Ort hat und dann auch irgendwie die Macht vor Ort dann auch vielleicht Gesetze umzusetzen oder nochmal den Finger drauf zu legen und zu schauen, dass Projekte auch irgendwie wirklich zustande kommen. Und das trägt ja auch dazu bei, dass es irgendwie eine Form von Selbstwirksamkeit gibt. Und ich glaube, das ist irgendwie immer ganz wichtig, wenn man sich aktivistisch beteiligt, dass man dieses Selbstwirksamkeitsgefühl hat, um dabei zu bleiben und nicht nur so Screaming into the void. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was ich für mich mitnehmen werde. Und vor allen Dingen, was ich auch irgendwie Menschen mitgeben will, die mich auch häufig fragen, was sie denn machen können, um sich politisch zu engagieren, dass es vielleicht nicht immer die EU oder der Bundestag sein muss, sondern dass man auf Landesebene auch schon ganz schön viel bewegen kann und ganz schön viel ändern kann und nicht so weit reisen muss und auch nicht irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Änderungsanträge galore lesen muss bis zum Umfallen. Ich glaube, das wäre so für mich der Take away. Oder möchtet ihr da noch was hinzufügen?
Sag mal überhaupt, wie du resümieren würdest. Für dich ist ja jetzt auch ein gewisser Haken an dieser Zeit. Was würdest du denn resümieren? Also unterschreibst du das, was Khaleesi jetzt gesagt hat, oder würdest du da eher ein bisschen widersprechen? Oder was dann zufühlt?
Ich hätte gesagt, wenn man die Chat-Kontrolle verhindern will, dann lohnt es sich nicht zwingend, zu einem Landtagsabgeordneten zu gehen.
Ah, nee, also Daniel, dann musst du jetzt aber kurz noch mal, also du bist ja auch Parteipolitiker. Also ich meine, und die Grünen sind jetzt Regierungspartei. Wenn man jetzt die Chat-Kontrolle verhindern will, kann man schon auch zu dir als Landtagsabgeordneten gehen und sagen, mach dich mal stark in deiner Partei, oder?
Definitiv. Und ich hab das auch gemacht. Also wir haben ja quasi Arbeitskreise und sind auch innerhalb der Digitalpolitiker, bei uns Grünen zumindest, vernetzt. Und ich hab auch die ein oder andere E-Mail an Europaabgeordnete geschrieben und telefoniert, was das Thema angeht. Aber das ist halt dann, dann hört es dann von dem, was ich machen kann. Und ich hab das auch bei anderen Landespolitikern versucht. Und naja, die haben halt vielleicht nicht den informatischen Background und verstehen das Problem nicht. Und ob die das dann weitergeben, weiß ich nicht. Man soll das trotzdem probieren. Ich glaube, in dem Fall ist, warum nicht, also man kann auch direkt die Europa abgucken.
Ja, aber ich glaube, da muss man auch immer realistisch bleiben. Also mir ging es jetzt nicht darum, konkrete Gesetzesvorhaben zu verhindern, wie die Chatkontrolle, dass das ein EU-Gesetz ist, dass man auch irgendwie auf die EU-gebende Regeln muss, ist völlig klar. Ich meinte eher so, für den das größere digitalpolitische Vorankommen ist ja sozusagen ein Bundesland. Und die Digitalpolitik, die da vor Ort passiert, auch ein Baustein davon, dass wir progressive Digitalpolitik machen können, weil wir halt immer noch eine föderale Struktur haben. Das war, glaube ich, gerade den Hebel, den ich eher beschreiben wollte.
Also ich möchte ein Plädoyer dafür halten, dass bitte alle ihre regionalen Landtagsabgeordneten mit ihrem Lieblingsthema nerven. Ich habe, das habe ich in den fünf Jahren immer wieder gemerkt, dass da, naja, so eine Art Barriere existiert, die irgendwie gar nicht sein müsste. Also es gibt so ein, ich habe das ja bei mir persönlich, bevor ich Abgeordneter gewesen bin, auch irgendwie gemerkt, dass man so eine gewisse Würde empfindet, jetzt diese Personen anzusprechen, obwohl die genau dafür da sind, angesprochen zu werden. Das ist meine Hauptaufgabe, dass ich mich um die Probleme, die zu mir getragen werden, mich kümmere. Und das geht nicht für mich, sondern auch für alle anderen. Und von daher bitte geht mit den Themen, die euch irgendwie betreffen und die euch am Herzen liegen, zu euren Vertretern. Und bitte geht nicht nur, wenn ihr jetzt Klimapolitik macht, zu den Grünen. Bitte geht auch zu den anderen Parteien, zu allen anderen Parteien. In der Vergangenheit war das auch immer so, dass die einzigen, die sich zugehört haben, sind dann wir. Und dann bei den Klimasachen. Und dann kriegt man dann auch den Frust ab, wenn man irgendwie was entscheiden muss, was vielleicht nicht jetzt so megacool war. Und da fehlt mir die Ansprache der anderen Parteien immer. Aber wie gesagt, meldet euch.
Okay, also ich hätte diverse andere Fragen, muss ich sagen. Ich glaube, so dieser Arbeitsalltag im Landtag und als Abgeordneter, der hat viele spannende Aspekte. Würdest du denn dein Wissen, du hast jetzt auch Prozesswissen, ja, du hast inhaltliches Wissen, das hast du dir an ein eigenes müssen und teilweise schon mit reingebracht. Aber du hast jetzt auch Prozesswissen, also wie Laufensachen und so. Würdest du das noch irgendwie weitergeben?
Ich habe dieses Prozesswissen versucht zu digitalisieren. Ich habe eine interne Wissensdatenbank aufgebaut mit Markdown, Zettelkasten und so weiter.
Also auch einen Blog, haben wir auch gesehen.
Ich habe einen Blog, da stehen auch ganz viele Dinge, aber da ist vielleicht nicht so das Prozesswissen drin. Aber ich habe das versucht, strukturiert aufzuarbeiten, dass ich irgendwie nachzuvollziehen kann, in welchem Protokoll hat welche Person welches Thema besprochen. Und wenn irgendwann klar ist, welche Ministerien es gibt, welche Ausschüsse es gibt, wer welche Themen bei uns in der Fraktion betrifft, versuche ich eine Übergabe so gut wie möglich zu machen, damit in Zukunft klar ist, wo die Linien in der Vergangenheit waren und wo man vielleicht noch was machen kann und wo nicht. Also das steht auf jeden Fall auf der Agenda. Also ich bin ja auch nicht weg. Also ich hab die Telefonnummern und die Three-Wire und Signal-IDs und so weiter von den Leuten und spreche und telefoniere auch und schreibe mit denen noch.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir sind gut in der Zeit, hätte ich fast gesagt. Es ist jetzt gleich Viertel nach Zehn. Deswegen erstmal vielen Dank, dass du da warst.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Es hat mir einen großen Spaß gemacht.
Und ich glaube, der Aufruf ist klar. Hier kontaktiert eure Abgeordneten, das ist mein Lieblingssatz. Aber diesmal so richtig, den könnt ihr dann auch noch vor Ort auf die Nerven gehen. Denn das hat natürlich auch sehr viel Wirkung. Und dann freuen wir uns, wenn ihr das nächste Mal wieder Dicke Bretter einschaltet. Diese Folge wird nach der Folge über die Sachverständigen-Anhörungen erscheinen.
Bei chaosradio.de, wo wir im Wechsel mit dem normalen Chaosradio die Dicke Bretter-Folgen veröffentlichen dürfen, mithilfe der Chaosradio Crew und der Musik von Erdgeiss, wollen wir mit Kotze hier mal erwähnen, denn ohne die könnten wir den nicht machen.
Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und wir sind bestimmt noch ein bisschen da und beantworten euch gerne Fragen.
Vielen Dank.